un pays qui vous le savez fait partie
des dix nouveaux entrants intégré dans
l'union il ya deux ans il a bénéficié à
plein de l'effet économique
au point que les estoniens sont
maintenant parmi les plus avancées en ce
qui concerne les nouvelles technologies
reportage à nos consignes et xavier
louise à sa manière depuis sa maison
dans les boîtes heavy participe à la
révolution technologique estonienne une
fois par mois 5 km à vélo jusqu'au pôle
informatique installé dans la
bibliothèque municipale pour ceux qui
n'ont ni ordinateur ni internet à la
maison elle vient vérifier que sa
retraite et payer
c'est une maman je préfère ici c'est
payé mes impôts fonciers et passe au
rouge est une manoeuvre de téléphones
portables de la vallée mais oswald jurf
tout ce que je peux faire par internet
marque dont mattel la paix internet elle
en ville une des applications les plus
courantes de scei technologie au
quotidien c'est le parking payé par
téléphone porte à un appel pour dire je
suis garé et le paiement s'effectue
à l'école numéro 21 le cours de maths
des 6e et terminer la prof rentrer dans
le site de l'école le contenu du cours
et les devoirs à faire
est ce que tous les jours mes parts on
regarde ce que j'ai fait à l'école et
les notes que j'ai ici ce n'est pas la
salle d'ordinateurs du lycée mais celle
du conseil des ministres c'est le chef
du gouvernement qui faisait le guide
aujourd'hui fête de l'europe l'occasion
d'expliquer l'objectif de l'estonie tout
faire par informatique pour réduire la
paperasserie et être plus efficace dans
la rue c'est encore avec un téléphone
portable que les agents vérifient le
payement des parkings des agents qui
travaillent pour une société privée sous
contrat avec la ville
aucun fonctionnaire le travail dans ce
service
à tallinn
quinze ans après sa sortie de l'urss
l'estonie cultive son image de modernité
avec en prévision pour cette année la
plus petite dette publique de toute
l'union européenne est le plus fort taux
de croissance